Traductor: Mayte Cedeño Tapia
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Tengo que confesaros una cosa: me llamo
Manuel Enciso y soy adicto a los datos.
Pero que no cunda el pánico porque eso
no es problema para vosotros ni para mí.
No es un problema para vosotros porque
no es contagioso, no os voy a pegar nada.
Yno es un problema para mí porque a mí
no me limita; a mí me da superpoderes.
No os veo muy convencidos; claro
porque no sabéis que debajo
llevo el traje de Superdato.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Si no es muy comercial, Superdatón.
(Risas)
Sí, esto le funcionaba mucho a Clark Kent.
Claro que Clark Kent y yo
no teníamos el mismo cuerpo.
Así que voy a utilizar otras armas,
yo también tengo mis armas
y las voy a poner en práctica aquí.
Concretamente, el método científico.
Voy a describir los superpoderes que tengo
y luego voy a hacer un experimento
en vivo y en directo.
Tengo dos superpoderes, a falta de uno.
El primer superpoder es que soy capaz
de ver la realidad tal cual es, diáfana.
No os parece muy interesante,
pasaros por Twitter
y me decís luego si eso es importante.
Y el segundo es que no solo soy capaz
de ver la realidad ahora,
sino que soy capaz de ver el futuro.
Los que tenemos estos superpoderes,
que tenemos nuestras reunioncillas
hablamos del primer superpoder
como interpretar los datos.
Y del segundo como estimada,
pronosticada, pero no os dejéis engañar,
es ver la realidad y ver el futuro, así.
Vamos a hacer el experimento: he recogido
los datos de una sesión TEDx anterior
y os puedo enseñar
algunas cosas muy interesantes.
779 personas fueron a esa sesión.
No os parece muy interesante.
Me voy a esforzar un poquito más.
Lo paso por el filtro
de la igualdad de género
y ahora ya voy a buscar
según la paridad y en fin,
se sacan conclusiones interesantes
respecto a los asistentes.
Tampoco os veo muy convencidos.
Claro, sé por qué, porque si miráis
a izquierda y a derecha
esa conclusión la podéis sacar vosotros.
Reconocéis fácilmente quién es hombre
y quién es mujer
y más o menos tenéis esa conclusión.
Voy a irme a algo que
no es tan fácil de descubrir: la edad.
Bueno, si miramos la distribución
de las edades, queda algo así.
Es una distribución normal, parece
ajustarse a una distribución normal.
No es una distribución normal y corriente
es que se llama así, distribución normal,
donde en el centro están
los valores más frecuentes
y los raritos son los extremos y eso
está muy bien porque tiene, en fin,
unas propiedades muy interesantes
que gustan mucho en las matemáticas,
pero lo que me gusta más
es lo que no se ve.
Hay gente que cuando rellena la ficha
no declara su edad.
Vamos a llamarle a eso
"derecho a la coquetería". (Risas)
Hay mucha gente que ejerce su derecho a
la coquetería y me he preocupado de mirar
si es más frecuente.
En fin, tenemos eso.
[Mujer 11 363. Hombre 18 387].
Poco, muy poquitos los que no ejercen
el derecho a la coquetería.
En ese diagrama de barras se expresa
creo que bastante bien.
Pero voy a expresarlo con
un diagrama de tartas y ahora sí
creo que os voy a terminar de convencer.
Voy a sacar una conclusión que quizás
no esperábamos antes de llegar aquí
y eso es lo bonito de los datos.
¡Somos más coquetos los hombres! (Risas)
¡Sí, señor! Ahí lo tenéis.
Sí, en realidad, voy a hacer un paréntesis
porque he utilizado diagramas
para expresar y comunicaros
la información de los datos.
Esto antes era muy complicado, antes
de que existiera esto que se llama
visualización de los datos.
Había que hacer una matriz
y entonces había que señalar
y yo tenía que irme para allá
y señalar la fila y la columna
y con un puntero láser indicaros
exactamente el dato que quería que vierais
y ahora no, ni mucho menos.
Ahora comunico una idea al auditorio
y sacáis la conclusión al instante.
Yo no sé si esto es un superpoder,
pero que los políticos
me compran esto mañana,
seguro, seguro.
Bueno pues, no es un superpoder, esto no,
lo otro sí, pero esto no. ¿Por qué?
Porque el mérito no es mío, el mérito
es vuestro; o tampoco es vuestro.
El mérito es de vuestro cerebro
y de los millones de años de evolución
común que recoge rápidamente
los colores, las formas, los tamaños,
los compara y saca la conclusión.
Así, al instante.
Está bien, pero desde el nacimiento
de Spiderman, sabemos que
un gran poder conlleva
una gran responsabilidad.
(Risas)
Entonces, podemos poner estos poderes
al servicio del bien y seremos superhéroes
o podemos ponerlos al servicio del mal
y seremos supervillanos.
Los supervillanos no quieren acabar
con la humanidad en este caso,
no os preocupéis.
Pero quieren engañarnos, confundirnos
y manipularnos.
Voy a poner algunos ejemplos traídos
del mundo real para ilustrar esto.
El primer ejemplo lo he traído
del mundo de la política.
Ya veo a gente crispada.
Sí, calentando el ambiente.
No, he anonimizado, he respetado
escrupulosamente las formas, los colores,
los tamaños de la presentación original,
pero he anonimizado
los dos partidos políticos
que van a aparecer ahí.
Es más, los dos retratos de
los líderes políticos los he sustituido
y, en fin, me he permitido eso
por dos personas
que tuvieron una rivalidad en su época
por un fin mucho más noble,
las formas no fueron luego tan nobles,
pero el fin sí que era ser
el mejor científico de su época.
Así que nos encontramos a
Thomas Alva Edison y Nicola Tesla
pugnando por ese galardón.
En unas elecciones autonómicas
ambos líderes obtuvieron esos resultados.
[Escaños: 1999-52. 2015: 16.
2012: 19. 2015: 11]
Pobrecito Thomas Alva Edison,
la debacle electoral que le llegaría
cuando llegó a la sede general del partido
y le dijeron eso qué es.
Vale, veo que hay gente al final,
sobre todo, los de la zona B
que me están diciendo que no se ve.
Claro, es que el que ha hecho el gráfico
no quería que los vierais.
Deliberadamente.
Vamos a hacer zoom y ahora fijaros
que en fondo rojo y con la letra azul
aparecen los años en que se han tomado
las mediciones: de 1999 a 2015, en un caso
y de 2012 a 2015, en el otro.
¡13 años de diferencia, por favor!
Me voy a ir al partido de Tesla
porque además la televisión autonómica
que mostró esto era afín a ese partido
y ahora no parece que fuera así.
Es decir, que el supervillano
que ha hecho esto tenía muy claro
la conclusión a la que quería llegar.
Claro, lo que hay que tener en cuenta
es que no todos los ejemplos
son tan burdos como estos, a veces es algo
más sutil y hay que conocer un poco más.
Voy a introducir un concepto,
el concepto de "correlación".
Cerrad las puertas que no se vaya nadie
porque introducimos este concepto
y si no os desconectáis.
No os desconectéis.
Primero, porque estamos en
el ecuador de la charla.
Y el tiempo que habéis perdido conmigo,
intentar aprovecharlo.
Y lo segundo y más importante
es porque todo el mundo conoce
el concepto de correlación, es algo
natural, intuitivo, sí lo es.
Lo explico, en lugar de medir un dato,
vamos a medir dos
y lo que vamos a estudiar
es si su comportamiento crece
o decrece proporcionalmente.
Es decir, lo que queremos estudiar es
si tiene un comportamiento proporcional.
También hay correlaciones cruzadas,
pero no me voy a meter en eso.
Es muy importante eso porque
las correlaciones nos permiten descubrir
un conocimiento nuevo que yo
luego explico y le doy un motivo.
Voy a poner un ejemplo: hace tres semanas,
un ejemplo muy reciente, salió un estudio
diciendo que las personas que sufren
obesidad, se había detectado
que sus mascotas también tienen obesidad.
Había una correlación muy fuerte
entre la obesidad de los dueños
y de sus mascotas.
Bueno, hay que explicar aquello
y se explicó: cuando una persona es obesa
normalmente tiene
hábitos de vida sedentarios
y si tienes hábitos de vida sedentarios
tu mascota va a ir muy poco a la calle.
O sea que es sumisa, tiene también
hábitos de vida sedentarios.
Voy a traerme un ejemplo del mundo real.
En este ejemplo, se miden
durante seis años las muertes violentas
en EE.UU., afortunadamente se ven
como han decrecido y en la línea roja
se ve la cuota de mercado del navegador
Internet Explorer.
Os dejo a vosotros que saquéis
las conclusiones.
Porque yo mientras me voy a dedicar,
voy a analizar un poquito más este tema,
que está muy bien,
de las muertes violentas en EE.UU.,
pero en tres meses.
En los tres meses el calorcito
parece que aprieta
y también aprietan los crímenes.
Y se ha medido en azul
los números de crímenes violentos,
de muertes violentas y en rojo,
efectivamente el consumo de helados
en ese mismo período.
Sí, cierto.
Si atendemos o intentamos extrapolar
las correlaciones
para buscar la causa-efecto, está clarísimo
que en EE.UU. tienen razón
los que abogan por no controlar las armas
para reducir la criminalidad.
Lo que hay que reducir es el navegador
Internet Explorer de todos los ordenadores
y el consumo de helados.
¡Ahí lo tenemos! (Aplausos)
En un ejemplo muy serio aparecido
este verano, en un blog,
se hablaba del calentamiento global.
Y la tendencia era esta.
Estamos libres, yo no sé mis compañeros
que han venido aquí
a hablar del apocalipsis
y este tipo de cosas.
¿Lo veis ahí claro?
La tendencia de la temperatura es
que está bajando, si no está estable,
está bajando.
Llegaron otros científicos posteriores
y dijeron "un momentito",
primero, se han tomado las temperaturas
en el mes de agosto
y el cambio climático se mide especialmente
en los períodos fríos.
Segundo, no se ha utilizado la media
que utilizan los meteorólogos
que es un modelo, no se ha utilizado
la media aritmética
porque aquí era más simple, era mejor,
mi ordenador no es muy potente.
Y tercero, veis que el registro empieza
en 1912, pero hay registros de temperatura
desde el siglo XIV, pero no interesaban
porque la huella del CO2
no es tan importante y ahí, si corregimos
estos tres errores, aparece esto.
Siento comunicaros que el cambio climático
tiene esta pinta, esta mala pinta.
Con esto, espero haberos convencido
de la necesaria protección
respecto a los supervillanos que
nos quieren hacer llegar otra cosa.
No queremos ser manipulados,
no queremos ser confundidos,
no queremos ser engañados,
como yo he hecho con vosotros
en esta charla.
¡Dos veces!
Al principio de la charla, primero,
os he dicho que los hombres somos
más coquetos que las mujeres, pero fijaros
que la diferencia es muy poca,
son números muy pequeñitos, pero claro
cuando los números son pequeñitos,
una diferencia pequeña también
lleva una gran variabilidad.
Además, el número de hombres era mejor
que el de mujeres, os lo mostré,
pero como no lo indiqué
no os fijasteis mucho.
Si corrijo esas dos cosas
y estudio la proporcionalidad
de los hombres coquetos sobre
hombres coquetos y de las mujeres coquetas
sobre las mujeres en general y además,
lo que hago es mostrar realmente
el resultado general, es que los hombres
y las mujeres somos iguales,
también en la coquetería.
Y el segundo engaño es que os he dicho
que esto de los datos no se pega.
Lo siento, estáis todos infectados.
(Aplausos)